let's go to our caller from the
eight-six zero area code caller from
eight-six Oh who's there hi David its
Joe from Connecticut hey Joe hey I've
got a question for you um so I know that
you're more on the social democrat side
I would kind of say I'm kind of more of
a pragmatist sort of moderate but I
enjoy hearing your perspective I would
love to hear your perspective on the
fact that in Sweden they don't have an
inheritance tax and they also don't have
minimum wage laws but they do have high
taxes and a pre robust social safety net
yes so I mean you just want my general
thoughts about that that reality or is
there did you have a particular question
about it well I would I guess love to
hear your thoughts on the fact that
their business climate as well as other
countries in the Nordic countries like
Scandinavia like Denmark Sweden Norway
they have a better business climate but
they have much higher tax rates on
individuals which is why they can afford
the robust social safety net that they
have at least that's my understanding I
would love to hear your thoughts on that
yeah that's generally true I mean as far
as so there's a couple different things
one they don't have the inheritance tax
I don't think that that is a blanket
statement that applies in all cases to
all people in all of the countries you
mentioned but to the extent that it does
exist you reduce the need for an
inheritance tax when you have a more
robust system of taxation and a more
robust social welfare system you reduce
the need to have as aggressive
inheritance taxes that's number one
you're right that minimum wage laws are
much more limited in some of those
countries part of the reason why is that
unions have a much stronger position and
thus the union negotiating power has
replaced in many cases the purpose and
objective of the minimum wage law so you
know there are right-wingers in the u.s.
that like to pick and choose one policy
they'll say Sweden has no minimum wage
right but they
really strong trade unions labor unions
which you oppose in the United States so
it's important not to let the right
cherry-pick of course and I guess my to
kind of piggyback off of that something
else in Sweden that I would also include
other countries India and Europe with
maybe the exception of the United
Kingdom is that while they do have
universal health care which I think if
the Republicans were smart they would
adopt the position of wanting to endorse
universal health care but it's not run
by the state per se a lot of the health
care is run through private companies
and at the same time - there's the
innovation from being done through
private companies but the government
well we pay or they can debate with that
we can debate that part I mean a lot of
the info innovation is happening at
publicly funded public universities so
that to say that that's B it's all being
done by private companies I would take
issue with but here's I think I would I
wouldn't say oh here's Hawaii I wouldn't
be so poor I thing about this the most
important thing I think is that there
are a number of different ways in which
Western developed nations have figured
out how to get health care to everybody
you have systems where the government is
actually the employer they run the
hospitals and they hire the doctors you
have systems where the government
establishes a single-payer system which
is the insurer but you still have a mix
of public and private health care
providers all of these systems are
systems that work other places and would
be better than the system that the US
has totally and I think that once again
I'm not gonna say that Republicans are
completely off the rails on this but no
there if they were smart I'll grant you
that the Democrats probably have more of
a winning position on this but I think
it would be smart for them to adopt this
because this is where they lose a lot
I'm the issue of health care and I think
if we want to have a realistic
discussion of covering everybody this
would be something that they would be
smart yeah hugely damaging to Democrats
if Republicans were for
care for all or universal health care it
would be hugely damaging because it
would deflate one of the main issues on
which the left is just crushing the
right at this point and and if
Republicans did that it would be a big
problem for Democrats thank you for the
call really appreciate it that's all the
time I have today but we will take calls
again on a future program thanks to
everybody who called in